[Music]
New Jersey's recently become the latest
state to suggest a ban on texting while
walking all this attention on the
dangers of distracted walking has led to
a pretty cool new service in today's
modern world you can watch what you're
doing or you can watch where you're
going but you can't do both and now you
don't have to
thanks to guiding hands simply request a
guiding hand and within seconds we'll be
at your side ready to guide you to your
destination you'll never have to look up
again ever
that's a promise it's a great idea it's
satisfying ending which it won't say
about my wedding night that king was
pretty unrealistic though that is not
how I
he was like hovering three feet above
her he was moving way too much yeah I
move very little it's a quick quiver and
then weeping that's right
Levi that's just perfect it's great now
why I won't our a fixer how do we get
delete when delete someone camera that's
time when to really be helping you I
know that day she almost didn't do
nothing that I didn't did not ask her to
do yep no there was a yoga class I'm
sure she farted up a conference room oh
my god well what do you think that yoga
stuffs about you're saying people do
yoga just so they can fart quieter all
secret fart sniffers delete responded
with a bitmoji oh there she is
in the healthy work
[Music]
you